und wir kommen nach deutschland und zu
einem tragischen unglück wie kann ein
kindergartenkind auf einem ausflug an
einen nahe gelegenen see einfach
verschwinden warum merken die
erzieherinnen erst nach der rückkehr in
die kita dass das kind der zwei jahre
alte adam nicht mehr da ist fragen die
sich jetzt nach dem tod von adam nicht
nur die menschen in magdeburg stellen
sondern auch die behörden und die
verantwortlichen sie müssen antworten
geben
der kleine adam aus magdeburg machte mit
seiner kita einen ausflug an einen see
dann verloren die betreuerin den
zweijährigen aus den augen jetzt ist der
kleine tod und sein vater mohammed klagt
an das war verantwortungslos
meine frau rief mich bei der arbeit an
sagte die polizei sei da ich solle nach
hause kommen
ich dachte mein sohn hätte etwas
angestellt aber die polizisten wollten
adams kissen und decke für ihre
spürhunde am freitagmorgen brachen drei
erzieherinnen der integrativen
kindertagesstätte am neustädter see mit
15 kindern zu einem ausflug auf erst als
sie zum mittagessen zur kita
zurückkehrten merkten sie dass adam
fehlte die polizei wurde benachrichtigt
mit einem rettungshubschrauber und
polizeihunden suchte ein großaufgebot
nach dem jungen die rettungskräfte
entdeckten schließlich das kind in einem
see treibend der junge war zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch am leben sein zustand
aber kritisch die reanimationsmaßnahmen
verliefen erfolglos
der kleine wurde sofort mit einem
hubschrauber in die uniklinik magdeburg
geflogen wenig später starb adam im
krankenhaus die familie ist fassungslos
ich verstehe nicht wie man mit kleinen
kindern zu so einem ort gehen kann
das werde ich nie verzeihen ich werde
die kita anzeigen
meine frau ist zusammengebrochen mein
großer sohn weint und schreit das seinem
bruder was meinem sohn passiert ist
hätte jedem passieren können
teddybären und kerzen stehen vor der
kita blumensträuße sind an das gitter
des kindergartens gebunden
sie erinnern an die furchtbare tragödie
und bild-reporter thilo scholtyseck hat
in dem tragischen fall recherchiert
thilo gibt es denn schon antworten auf
die drängende frage warum haben die
erzieherinnen nichts gemerkt haben nicht
gemerkt dass adamek ist das ist die
große frage das ist der absolute
mittelpunkt der ermittlungen der kripo
es geht um die frage wieso sie es nicht
bemerkt haben bzw erst mit einem
zeitverzug von fast einer stunde die
frauen sind
das hat uns die geschäftsführung des
kita trägers mitgeteilt mittlerweile
freigestellt wurden
sie sind mittlerweile freigestellt
worden und bisher aber noch nicht zeugen
schaftlich vernommen wurden alle drei
befinden sich im status der
beschuldigten
ihnen wird vorgeworfen eine
fürsorgepflicht verletzung mit
todesfolge der straff rahmen ist bis zu
drei jahren allerdings sagen die
ermittler müssen die frauen erst
rechtliches gehör bekommen
das ist bisher noch nicht erfolgt das
soll jetzt in den nächsten tagen
erfolgen was die staatsanwaltschaft als
erstes gemacht hat ist die obduktion zu
anzumelden es gibt noch kein offizielles
ergebnis man will nicht nur die
todesursache mit der obduktion klären
sondern auch die frage ob adam
vielleicht vorerkrankungen hatte es wird
toxologischen untersuchung geben weil er
bei der obduktion
aber das wichtigste für die ermittler
ist natürlich die aussagen der drei
beteiligten kindergärtnerinnen die
bisher krankgeschrieben sind offiziell
und vom kita träger freigestellt
nichtsdestotrotz werden natürlich
weitere ermittlungen gemacht
ermittler sprechen mit anderen
mitarbeiter nämlich unmittelbar an dem
tag mit bei der ausflug fahren aber die
aussagen machen können zu den zeitlichen
abläufen dass man genau weiß wie lange
es wirklich gedauert hat bis er gefunden
bis er überhaupt erstmal als vermisst
gemeldet wurde mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren